[Music]
in an era defined by rapid urbanization
and a burgeoning global population the
challenge of producing sufficient food
sustainably has never been greater
cities are expanding and with them the
demand for fresh locally sourced produce
is on the rise traditional agricultural
methods while reliable often fall short
in meeting these growing needs
especially in densely populated urban
areas where space is at a premium this
is where innovative solutions like
vertical hydroponic farming come into
play offering a promising alternative to
Conventional farming practices
traditional farming methods while time
tested often struggle to keep Pace with
these escalating demands the vast
expanses of land required the dependency
on weather conditions and the
significant water usage are just a few
of the challenges faced by conventional
agriculture moreover transporting
produce from rural farms to Urban
centers can lead to increased carbon
emissions and reduced freshness of the
food by the time it reaches consumers
these limitations highlight the need for
more efficient and sustainable farming
techniques enter vertical hydroponic
farming an Innovative approach to
agriculture that offers a Beacon of Hope
for the future of food production by
utilizing vertical space and hydroponic
technology this method allows for the
cultivation of crops in environments
where traditional farming would be
impossible or impractical from
skyscrapers to small Urban Apartments
vertical hydroponic systems can be
adapted to fit a variety of spaces
making it a versatile solution for
modern agricultural challenges this
method ingeniously combines vertical
space optimization with the principles
of Hydroponics creating a potent
solution for growing more food in less
space Hydroponics the practice of
growing plants without soil uses
nutrient-rich water to nourish the
plants directly this not only reduces
the need for large plots of land but
also significantly cuts down on water
usage compared to traditional soil-based
farming the vertical Arrangement further
maximizes the use of available space
allowing for higher crop yields in
smaller areas imagine fresh flavorful
produce flourishing year round
unconstrained by the limitations of
Seasons or geographical boundaries
vertical hydroponic systems can be
controlled to provide optimal growing
conditions regardless of the external
environment this means that even in the
dead of winter or in Aid regions with
little rainfall crops can Thrive and
produce Bountiful Harvest
the ability to grow food locally and
consistently not only enhances food
security but also reduces the carbon
footprint associated with long-distance
transportation of produce this is the
promise of vertical hydroponic farming a
method that empowers us to cultivate
food in urban centers Aid Landscapes and
even within the confines of our homes
whether it's a large-scale commercial
operation or a small personal Garden
vertical hydroponic systems can be
tailored to meet the needs of different
Growers this flexibility makes it an
attractive option for a wide range of
applications from feeding urban
populations to providing fresh produce
in remote or resource scarce areas as we
delve deeper into this revolutionary
approach we'll uncover the Myriad
benefits it offers from maximizing space
utilization to minimizing our
environmental footprint vertical
hydroponic farming not only makes
efficient use of space but also promotes
sustainable agricultural practices by
reducing the need for pesticides and
herbicides conserving water and lowering
carbon emissions this method aligns with
the growing Global emphasis on
environmental stewardship and
sustainable development this essay will
serve as your comprehensive Guide to the
world of vertical hydroponic farming
providing you with the knowledge and
inspiration to embark on your own
growing journey we'll explore the
various types of vertical hydroponic
systems the best practices for setting
them up and the key factors to consider
for successful cultivation whether
you're a novice Gardener or an
experienced grower you'll find valuable
insights and practical tips to help you
get started and thrive in this exciting
field whether you're an urban dweller
with limited space an environmentally
conscious individual seeking Sustainable
Solutions or simply a food Enthusiast
eager to savor the freshest produce
vertical hydroponic farming holds
immense potential it offers a way to
reconnect with nature even in the Heart
of the City and to take an active role
in producing your own food the sense of
satisfaction and accomplishment that
comes from growing your own vegetables
and herbs is unparalleled and the
benefits extend beyond just the produce
itself get ready to discover the
fascinating world of growing up where
Innovation meets sustainability to
reshape the future of Agriculture as we
journey through the intricacies of
vertical hydroponic farming you'll gain
a deeper appreciation for the Ingenuity
and potential of this method together
we'll explore how it can transform not
only the way we grow food but also how
we think about our relationship with the
environment and our role in creating a
more sustainable future
vertical Hydroponics is at its core a
marriage of two groundbreaking Concepts
vertical farming and hydroponics this
Innovative approach is revolutionizing
the way we think about agriculture
especially in urban environments where
space is a premium vertical farming as
the name suggests involves growing crops
in vertically stacked layers maximizing
space utilization this method is
particularly beneficial in densely
populated urban areas where horizontal
space is often limited allowing for the
cultivation of a significant amount of
produce in a relatively small footprint
imagine transforming rooftops balconies
and even indoor spaces into lush green
Gardens vertical farming makes this
possible turning underutilized spaces
into productive agricultural hubs
hydroponics on the other hand is a
soilless method of growing plants where
their roots are immersed in a
nutrient-rich water solution this
technique allows for precise control
over the nutrients the plant receive
leading to faster growth rates and
higher yields compared to traditional
soil-based farming this eliminates the
need for traditional soil and allows for
greater control over the plant's
nutrient intake by carefully monitoring
and adjusting the nutrient solution
Growers can ensure that plants receive
the optimal balance of nutrients
resulting in healthier and more robust
crops when combined these two techniques
give rise to Vertical hydroponic farming
a system where plants are grown
vertically in stacked layers this method
not only maximizes space but also
enhances the efficiency of resource use
making it a sustainable option for
modern agriculture with their Roots
suspended in a nutrient-rich water
solution that is continuously circulated
plants in a vertical hydroponic system
can thrive in a controlled environment
this continuous circulation ensures that
the plants receive a steady supply of
nutrients and oxygen promoting vigorous
growth this method offers a plethora of
advantages over traditional farming
including increased yield reduced water
consumption and the ability to grow
crops year round regardless of external
weather conditions the efficient use of
water is particularly noteworthy as
hydroponic systems can use up to 90%
less water than conventional farming
methods Additionally the controlled
environment of a vertical hydroponic
system eliminates the need for harmful
pesticides and herbicides resulting in
cleaner and safer produce this not only
benefits the consumer but also reduces
the environmental imp impact of farming
imagine a tower of leafy greens their
Roots bathed in a nutrient-rich solution
reaching towards the sunlight streaming
through a window this vision of urban
agriculture is becoming a reality
bringing fresh locally grown produce to
City dwellers this is the essence of
vertical Hydroponics a method that
empowers us to cultivate fresh flavorful
produce in any environment whether it's
a small apartment a rooftop or a
commercial building vertical Hydroponics
can transform any space into a
productive Garden regardless of space
constraints or soil quality vertical
Hydroponics offers a versatile solution
for growing a wide variety of crops from
leafy greens and herbs to strawberries
and tomatoes the possibilities are
endless as we delve further into the
intricacies of this Innovative approach
we'll explore the various types of
vertical hydroponic systems each system
has its unique advantages and can be
tailored to suit different needs and
environments we'll also discuss the
ideal crops for this method highlighting
which plants Thrive best in a vertical
hydroponic setup understanding the
specific requirements of different crops
can help you achieve the best results
finally we'll provide a step-by-step
guide to setting up your own vertical
hydroponic Farm whether you're a
beginner or an experienced Gardener
these tips and techniques will help you
get started on your vertical farming
Journey bringing the future of
Agriculture into your own
home venturing into the realm of
vertical hydroponic farming you'll
encounter a variety of systems each with
its own unique features and advantages
these systems are designed to maximize
space efficiency and optimize plant
growth making them ideal for urban
environments or areas with limited
horizontal Space by stacking plants
vertically these systems allow for a
higher density of crops in a smaller
footprint which is particularly
beneficial for commercial Growers and
hobbyists alike choosing the right
system for your needs depends on factors
such as available space budget and the
types of crop you wish to grow it's
important to assess your specific
requirements and constraints before
making a decision for instance if you
have a small balcony or a compact indoor
space a tower system might be the most
suitable option on the other hand if you
have a larger area and want to grow a
variety of crops an A-frame or vertical
nft system could be more appropriate
let's delve into some of the most
popular vertical hydroponic systems each
offering unique benefits and Catering to
different growing needs understanding
the characteristics of Beach system will
help you make an informed choice and set
up a successful hydroponic garden one
Tower systems Tower systems are a
favorite among vertical hydroponic
enthusiasts particularly for growing
herbs strawberries and leafy greens
these systems are designed to be Compact
and efficient making them perfect for
small spaces the vertical Arrangement
allows for easy access to each plant
simplifying maintenance and harvesting
these systems feature vertically stacked
pots or channels through which the nut
nutrient solution flows creating a
microclimate ideal for year- round
growth The Continuous Flow of nutrients
ensures that plants receive a consistent
supply of essential elements promoting
healthy and vigorous growth Additionally
the vertical design helps to reduce the
risk of pests and diseases as the plants
are elevated off the ground Tower
systems are known for their efficient
use of space and their ability to
utilize natural sunlight reducing energy
consumption by positioning the towers in
a way that maximizes light exposure
you can take advantage of natural light
to support plant growth further
enhancing the sustainability of your
hydroponic setup two A-frame systems as
the name suggests A-frame systems
resemble the shape of the letter A with
plants growing on both sloping sides
this design not only maximizes the use
of vertical space but also ensures that
each plant receives optimal light
exposure the sloping sides allow light
to reach all parts of the plant
promoting even growth and reducing the
likelihood of shading this ingenious
design maximizes light exposure for each
plant promoting Healthy Growth the
A-frame structure also provides
excellent air circulation which is
crucial for preventing mold and mildew
by ensuring that air can flow freely
around the plants you can create a
healthier growing environment and reduce
the need for chemical treatments A-frame
systems are also relatively easy to
maintain making them a great option for
both beginners and experienced Growers
the straightforward design allows for
simple set set up in maintenance while
the sturdy structure ensures long-term
durability whether you're just starting
out or looking to expand your existing
hydroponic garden an A-frame system can
provide a reliable and efficient
solution three vertical nft nutrient
film technique the nutrient film
technique or nft is a popular hydroponic
method that involves growing plants in a
shallow stream of nutrient solution that
flows continuously over their Roots this
technique is highly efficient as it
ensures that the plants receive a
constant supply of nutrients and oxygen
promoting rapid growth and high yields
vertical nft systems adapt this
technique to a vertical orientation
making them ideal for fast growing
greens like lettuce and spinach the
vertical Arrangement allows for a high
density of plants in a small area making
it perfect for urban farming or
commercial
operations by utilizing the nft method
in a vertical setup you can achieve
impressive growth rates and maximize
your Harvest each of these systems
offers a unique approach to Vertical
hydroponic farming catering to different
needs and preferences whether you're
looking for a compact solution for a
small space or a high yield system for
commercial production there's a vertical
hydroponic system that can meet your
requirements by understanding the
strengths and limitations of each system
you can make an informed decision and
set up a successful hydroponic garden as
you delve deeper into your research
consider factors such as space
availability budget constraints and the
the specific crops you wish to cultivate
to determine the system that best aligns
with your goals by carefully evaluating
your options and planning your setup you
can create a thriving vertical
hydroponic garden that meets your needs
and supports sustainable efficient food
production the beauty of vertical
hydroponic farming lies in its
versatility allowing you to cultivate a
wide array of crops within the comfort
of your home or in larger commercial
settings however certain plants Thrive
better than others in this controlled
environment When selecting crops for
your vertical hydroponic system consider
factors such as growth habit nutrient
requirements and light preferences leafy
greens with their shallow root systems
and rapid growth Cycles are particularly
well suited for vertical Hydroponics
imagine a tower overflowing with vibrant
lettuce crisp spinach and
nutrient-packed kale all grown without a
spec of soil herbs too flourish in these
systems they aromatic leaves adding a
touch of freshness to your culinary
Creations small fruits such as
strawberries and cherry tomatoes also
adapt well to Vertical Hydroponics their
vibrant colors adding a touch of cheer
to your indoor garden When selecting
fruit bearing plants opt for compact
varieties that won't overwhelm the
system's structure by carefully
considering the growth requirements of
each crop and selecting those that are
best suited for vertical Hydroponics
you'll be well on your way to harvesting
a bountiful and diverse array of fresh
produce year round